Connaissez-vous la forêt de Brocéliande ?
Officiellement, la forêt de Paimpont.
Mais non. Paimpont :
une commune de Bretagne, située
dans le département d'Ille-et-Vilaine.
Elle est le théâtre de légendes
et de mythes fascinants.
Je suis sûr que vous avez déjà entendu
parler du roi Arthur,
des Chevaliers de la Table ronde,
de la fée Morgane.
C'est aussi dans cette forêt
que se cacherait Merlin l'Enchanteur.
Evan, le Breton de la team
Epicurieux, est parti à sa recherche.
Oui, et je ne suis pas le seul
à le chercher, Jamy
car Brocéliande est une forêt
où la frontière entre mythes et réalité
est un peu floue.
Ici, il y a près de 400000 visiteurs
qui viennent découvrir
une vingtaine de sites,
tous liés aux légendes arthuriennes,
autrement dit aux histoires du roi Arthur,
de ses amis, mais aussi de ses ennemis.
La plupart de ces légendes sont nées
au Moyen Âge,
entre le XIIᵉ et le XIIIᵉ siècle.
Pour évoquer ce bagage culturel,
on utilise souvent l'expression
"matière de Bretagne", mais en réalité,
ces histoires ne sont pas nées en Bretagne,
mais de l'autre côté de la Manche.
En 1137, l'évêque gallois
Geoffroy de Monmouth
publie un livre intitulé
L'histoire des rois de Bretagne.
Mais la Bretagne dont il parle, c'est
la Grande-Bretagne
qu'on appelle à l'époque l'île de Bretagne
et non notre Bretagne armoricaine.
Il donne alors vie à un roi légendaire
nommé Arthur.
C'est un guerrier sans peur, à la tête
d'un immense
empire rassemblant toute l'île de Bretagne
ainsi que l'Irlande, l'Islande,
la Norvège, le Danemark
et une bonne partie de la Gaule.
Arthur est quasiment invincible,
notamment grâce à son conseiller
Merlin l'Enchanteur.
C'est un magicien capable
de maîtriser tous les éléments :
le vent, la pluie, le feu.
C'est un peu l'ancêtre d'Harry Potter.
En compagnie des chevaliers de la Table
ronde, Arthur et Merlin
se lancent en quête du Saint-Graal.
Une mystérieuse coupe
qui aurait été utilisée par le Christ
et ses apôtres lors de son dernier repas.
Elle est censée assurer la paix
et la prospérité du royaume.
Ce roman est un best seller au Moyen Âge,
tant et si bien que la légende d'Arthur
finit par franchir la Manche et débarquer
en France grâce à Chrétien de Troyes.
L'auteur français
en reprend tous les ingrédients
et situe lui aussi la forêt de Brocéliande
en Grande-Bretagne et non en Bretagne.
Mais alors, me direz vous,
comment la forêt de Brocéliande s'est-elle retrouvée
en Ille-et-Vilaine ?
Eh bien, au XIXᵉ siècle,
le chemin de fer arrive en Bretagne.
Pour attirer les touristes,
on n'hésite pas à s'arranger
avec ces vieilles légendes.
Il s'agit de fabriquer de toutes pièces
l'image d'une Bretagne typique
et romantique.
Certains lieux sont alors rebaptisés.
C'est le cas de la forêt de Paimpont,
en Ille-et-Vilaine, qu'on associe
à Brocéliande,
la fameuse forêt de Merlin l'Enchanteur.
Bien sûr que Brocéliande est en Bretagne
et Merlin aussi.
Je sais juste pas où il se trouve,
mais mon petit doigt me dit qu'il
n'est probablement pas loin de cet étang
ni de cette épée magique.
J'ai déjà vérifié pour vous,
il n'est pas sur la plage.
Contrairement aux apparences,
cette épée n'est pas Excalibur.
Elle s'appelle l'épée des rois.
C'est elle qui a permis à Arthur d'accéder au trône
lorsque, lors d'un combat de chevaliers,
il est le seul à pouvoir
la sortir de son rocher.
Si vous vous souvenez du dessin
animé Merlin l'Enchanteur de Walt Disney,
c'est plus ou moins l'histoire de L'épée
des rois qui est racontée.
Et Excalibur alors ?
Excalibur, Evan, c'est une autre épée,
celle ci.
L'épée la plus célèbre de la légende arthurienne.
Elle donne à Arthur une force surhumaine.
Quant à son fourreau,
il le protège de toutes les blessures.
Selon la légende,
une fois dans la main du roi,
elle brille plus fort que 30 torches.
Serait-ce la vraie ?
Mais attention, le roi Arthur
n'en est pas le propriétaire.
Il en est le simple gardien
le temps de son règne.
C'est la fée Viviane, dont Merlin
est très amoureux, qui a demandé aux elfes
de fabriquer cette épée pour Arthur après
qu'il a cassé la fameuse épée du rocher.
Elle a été forgée dans un métal enchanté,
si dur que rien ne peut le briser.
Mais surtout, elle a le pouvoir
d'assurer la victoire à son porteur.
Grâce à cette arme magique, Arthur réussit
à rassembler tous les peuples de Bretagne
et de Grande-Bretagne et à réunir
autour de lui les plus valeureux
de ses chevaliers, les fameux chevaliers
de la Table Ronde à Camelot.
Bon alors, il en est où Evan,
avec Merlin l'Enchanteur ?
- J'arrive, Jamy !
Peut-être que Merlin
l'Enchanteur se cache ici dans le
Val sans retour, l'endroit le plus visité de
la forêt de Brocéliande.
Forêt que je vous conseille vivement de visiter
avec des conteurs ou des conteuses.
Ce sont des professionnels qualifiés
qui se documentent,
qui fouillent les archives, qui lisent
de nombreux livres pour vous raconter
les vraies histoires de Brocéliande,
notamment celle du Val sans retour.
Cette partie de la forêt serait ensorcelée.
Approchez-vous,
je vais vous raconter l'histoire.
Jadis, la fée Morgane, la demi-sœur du roi
Arthur, était très amoureuse
d'un chevalier, Guyomard.
Sauf que celui-ci l'a trompée.
Alors elle a jeté un charme sur tout
le fond de la vallée
qui dit que tout homme, s'il a été trompeur
et même en pensée,
ne pourra plus jamais sortir du Val,
le Val sans retour.
Bon, normalement,
moi je devrais réussir à en sortir.
Vous avez vu cet arbre ?
C'est l'emblème de Brocéliande.
Ça aurait pu faire une bonne cachette
pour Merlin.
Mais en réalité, l'arbre n'a
rien à voir avec les histoires
de la légende arthurienne.
Eh non ! Rien à voir !
Cet arbre étrange,
que l'on appelle L'arbre
d'or est en réalité une œuvre d'art créée
sur place à la suite d'un terrible incendie.
En septembre 1990, deux méga-feux dévastent
plusieurs centaines d'hectares
de landes et de forêts du Val sans retour.
Les dégâts sont tels
qu'un gigantesque élan de solidarité
s'organise dans la région.
L'association du Val sans retour,
entourée de milliers de bénévoles,
replante
plus de 500000 arbres à Brocéliande.
Pour célébrer l'événement,
le sculpteur François Davin
crée cette œuvre à partir d'un
châtaignier calciné dont la silhouette
rappelle les bois d'un cerf.
Il l'a recouvert de 5000 feuilles d'or.
Entouré de cinq chênes noircis,
l'arbre d'or symbolise le caractère
fragile et précieux de la forêt.
D'ailleurs, en 2022, les flammes
ont à nouveau ravagé le sud du Val
sans retour, comme pour nous rappeler
que la forêt est fragile.
Bon Evan, tu l'as trouvé Merlin ?
J'ai peut-être une chance
de le trouver ici.
Tu entends ce cœur qui bat, Jamy ?
C'est peut-être Merlin ou pas.
La légende raconte que l'on peut entendre
deux cœurs battre dans ce rocher.
On l'appelle le Rocher des faux amants.
Encore un coup de la fée Morgane
qui était éperdument amoureuse
du chevalier Guyomard, qu'elle a surpris
dans les bras d'une autre.
Ni une ni deux, elle les a changés
en rocher, mais un rocher
qui a la forme d'un cœur brisé
comme le cœur de Morgane.
Autre preuve que cette forêt est
magique, Jamy, la couleur de la terre
et de la roche. Ce serait peut-être bien
un coup de Merlin ?
Désolé Evan, je vais encore te décevoir.
Si les rochers autour de toi
sont de couleur violette ou rouge,
ça n'a rien à voir avec la magie.
Il s'agit de schiste rouge,
une roche très commune
en Bretagne et plus particulièrement
là où tu te trouves, à Brocéliande.
Et certains disent aussi que c'est le sang
des fées qui se serait déversé
partout dans Brocéliande
jusqu'à en teinter la terre.
Mais bon bref, Jamy,
revenons-en à notre quête de Merlin.
Je crois avoir trouvé une nouvelle piste.
C'est la fontaine de Barenton.
Elle est citée dans de nombreux textes
depuis 1160
comme étant une fontaine magique
qui fait des bulles.
Ce serait sa façon de communiquer
avec les humains. Moment démo !
Fontaine de Barenton,
dis-moi où se cache Merlin l'Enchanteur ?
Je le cherche partout depuis 1h.
Visiblement,
la réponse ne coule pas de source.
D'après la légende, Merlin
aurait enchanté la fontaine d'eau
pour apprendre à Viviane,
sa bien aimée, à faire tomber la pluie.
Une autre légende affirme
que les fées naissent dans ces bulles.
Bon, c'est mignon,
mais il y a une autre explication.
D'abord, il faut savoir
que la température de cette eau
est glaciale : entre 4 et 10 degrés.
Ces bulles ne se sont donc pas formées
comme les geysers en Islande,
sous l'effet de la chaleur.
Elles sont liées à un dégagement de gaz,
principalement de l'azote. Pas dangereux,
c'est le principal composant de l'air
que nous respirons.
Il serait dû à la décomposition organique
remontant par une sorte de siphon
formé dans les couches géologiques
sous la fontaine.
C'est la faible solubilité de l'azote dans l'eau
qui explique le dégagement
des bulles en surface.
Voilà Evan, tu l'as ta réponse !
Clair comme de l'eau de roche, non ?
Moi je crois surtout que cette fontaine
est vraiment magique.
Et je ne suis pas le seul à le penser
car des centaines de visiteurs
viennent chaque jour ici
pour se recueillir, pour se ressourcer,
voire même pour buller.
Justement,
je trouve qu'on bulle un peu trop !
Nous, ce qu'on cherche, c'est Merlin.
J'ai quand même trouvé son tombeau, Jamy.
Ce que les gens prennent
pour son tombeau.
Car entre vous et moi,
Merlin n'est pas vraiment enterré ici.
En fait, il est partout dans la forêt
car Merlin a été victime
d'un sort de la fée Viviane qui,
par amour pour lui,
l'a enfermé dans une prison d'air afin
qu'il reste à ses côtés pour l'éternité.
Donc, concrètement,
Merlin pourrait très bien être
à la cime des arbres
ou pourquoi pas derrière ce rocher.
Bon Merlin,
j'en ai marre de te chercher partout.
Si tu existes vraiment,
prouve-le ! En me transformant,
je sais pas moi, en Prince de Brocéliande.
Jamy, c'est moi, Evan !
- Aide-moi !
- Evan ?
Alors là, la science,
la science comme tu dis,
je crois qu'elle ne peut plus rien pour toi.
Voilà, si vous avez envie
d'embrasser une grenouille pour qu'Evan
se réincarne en être humain,
n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir !
J'espère que vous avez apprécié
cette vidéo, que tout comme moi,
elle vous a enchantés.
On se retrouve très vite,
dimanche prochain.
D'ici là, chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux,
passez une excellente semaine,
la plus magique possible.